and care about actions your intentions
do not matter I don't care if you took
the vows and didn't intend to get
divorced if you still got divorced
because you saw some Tik toks sorry this
idea that women are leaving left and
right for good reasons it's just not
true most of the time when women leave
it's because they are not submissive
they were not raised to be a wife and
they do not take their vows seriously
they were sold a Disney Dream that their
husband should have everything and have
no flaws and are in a gynocentric social
order that tells them they're amazing
special and awesome all the time and
never talk about what they do wrong in a
relationship